uh talk about um
you first kind of start like I feel like
you became like the the face of
your generation of music for about a
year you were kind of like when we
thought of the sound when I think of
SoundCloud era of rap I think of you
you're the first first name face that
pops in my head of course the clout era
I think a little pump is that fair yeah
SoundCloud era yeah just that whole I
think you're you're like on the [ __ ]
like the mount the mountain Rushmore of
that [ __ ] yeah 100 percent
for good or for bad and I call those
years of rap kind of I kind of call them
the dark ears because it kind of I feel
like you're and I still I did stick up
for you a lot because I actually really
liked your records thank you appreciate
it
um like I really [ __ ] with your joints
like I was like yo but the music is hard
as to where some of your counterparts
during that time it was a hundred
percent about
the Antics on the internet
well I feel like you had a lot of stupid
[ __ ] you were doing on the internet
and you were following it up at least
with dope records yeah you know what I
mean of course but then the records kind
of started to fall off a little do you
feel like it was because you were just
lost in the sauce and you weren't as
focused on music you're worried about I
mean you were [ __ ] you were [ __ ]
living life bro for real you was [ __ ]
V-Rod at least I think you're [ __ ]
Veronica Rodriguez one of my favorite
porn stars he was [ __ ] everybody saw
everything but you were like you were
really living that rap rap I mean you
still are obviously you just we'll talk
about white Porsche uh but
um did you ever feel like you know
during that time like you kind of had to
compete with the last crazy [ __ ] you did
to kind of stay on the top of people's
minds instead of focusing on the music
per se
to me
I I didn't really care what people think
about me because at the end of the day
they're going to criticize they're going
to hate they're going to say whatever
they're going to say right as long as
they keep my name in their mouth
you know that's fair
and
I did everything I wanted to do I moved
my mom out of the hood yeah my whole
family out of the hood yeah my family's
straight
I got nothing else to worry about I'm
set that is true man like whatever
people got to say about me they keep
talking but I'm still here